this is one of the strangest videos i
have seen in a long time
in an absurd absurd phone call the story
almost slipped through the weekend kind
of quietly but it's completely outrage
outrageous donald trump had a phone call
with professional golfer john daly now
you might say why well maybe they were
talking about golf actually they were
talking about foreign policy donald
trump was on the phone
with professional golfer john daly
and he talked about nuclear weapons
and claimed that he once threatened
putin with bombing moscow
that's the story it it it makes no sense
it's it's almost beyond belief like what
what why is trump on the phone with daly
why are they talking about foreign
policy
it's all bizarre and of course if it's
true that trump threatened putin with
bombing moscow
that's a fascinating story too let's
take a listen to this this is trump on
speaker
speaking to john daly who increasingly
looks like glenn beck interestingly
enough and um
listen to what he had to
you
say
he was a friend of mine i got a long
grade with him i say vladimir if you're
doing we're hitting moscow i said we're
gonna hit moscow and he sort of believed
me like five percent ten percent that's
all you need he never did it during my
time john you know
it's funny how she didn't bother you
either
i like how he says by the way chi
yeah now she didn't bother me
that'll be next yeah you know that's
going to be next taiwan will be next you
won't have any computer chips they'll
blow them off the face of the earth
now i i actually agree with trump there
there's a real possibility that china is
increasingly salivating over the idea of
doing something with taiwan given what's
going on in in ukraine right now with
russia um but how wild is this trump
told putin he would hit moscow if
it
this this was previously unknown in
terms of our geopolitical relations and
and foreign policy that trump had
threatened putin with bombing their
capital city but i mean
i i looked and there's no record of that
that i was able to find now
it's possible trump meant he told putin
he wanted to hit the moscow strip clubs
that it is possible that that's what
trump meant we don't want to rule it out
but i think he is talking about bombing
now the other someone wrote to me and
said david
is it possible trump thought he was
speaking
with jon stewart
from the daily show instead of john daly
like maybe that's the explanation and as
funny as that is i don't think it really
makes a difference because this is still
something we we did not know donald
trump supposedly told putin but do we
believe this like trump even said i was
friends with putin i don't know i mean
is is that even really true and this
could be another one of these instances
of trump wanting to be the alpha in
front of the pro athlete it's all very
very strange but trump very casually
mentioning something to a golfer
that if true
it's an incredible story that that would
be incredible if that is a foreign
policy discussion that took place it's
also silly to talk about this with john
daly
because daley's an expert
in latin america not in russia okay
anyway um
that
now of course it might just all be a lie
who knows why is trump on the phone with
a golfer and saying these things how do
these phone calls get scheduled in the
first place
do you think it's a random call or what
what's the backstory it's bizarre and
one other note
some people are reacting as if trump
said
i threatened putin with nuking moscow
it's not at all clear from what trump
says that he's talking about nukes now
it's true
maybe he is i don't know i don't think
he's talking about nuking moscow he's
talking about bombing moscow
it's all crazy is the point and why
trump is having these conversations with
pro golfers or former pro golfers i
genuinely don't know
but it is another reminder
that it's going to take years for us to
know the full scope of the absurdity
that was foreign policy under trump if
you're just listening today we'll have
this clip on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman's show and by the
way real quick real quick i'm going to
say more about this tomorrow we are
launching a coaching initiative for up
and coming
podcasters youtubers and content
creators we are um accepting
applications at davidpakman.com
coaching if you are already a content
creator okay that's the now listen
carefully to that
if you were already a content creator
with a youtube channel podcast or
whatever you can apply for free coaching
from me at davidpakman.com
coaching we're going to be doing uh
recorded
coaching sessions with a small curated
group of creators the goal being to grow
your platforms and your shows and your
content creation so you can apply at
davidpakman.com coaching it's a very
cool new thing i'm super excited to do
it sort of like a giving back i'm going
to help people after i was helped um you
can uh apply at davidpakman.com coaching
and i'll have more information about
that for you tomorrow
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us
ag-1 by athletic greens is a delicious
drink that just simplifies the entire
thing it's one product you get all of
the things you need 75 vitamins minerals
and whole food-sourced ingredients it's
a multi-vitamin it's a multi-mineral
it's a probiotic green food blend in one
daily serving really easy high quality
bioavailable ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag-1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good helps me get everything i'm trying
to get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes